Why water boils at 100 degrees
and methane at minus 161.
Why blood is red and
grass is green.
Why diamond is hard
and wax soft.
Why glaciers flow and iron gets
hard when you hammer it.
The answers to all these
problems have come from
structural analysis.
That's how the Nobel Prize
winner Max Perutz summed up
x-ray crystallography.
Never heard of it?
Don't worry.
Not many people have.
Yet it's arguably one of the
greatest innovations of the
20th century.
28 Nobel prizes have been
awarded to projects related to
crystallography.
And the very first of those
is where it all began.
It's now 100 years since,
following early work by Max
Von Laue, the first structures
were determined by father and
son team, William and
Lawrence Bragg.
In 1913, they fired a narrow
beam of x-rays at a humble
salt crystal and photographed
the diffraction pattern as the
crystals split the beam
into many rays.
Lawrence soon realised that this
pattern held the clues to
the atomic structure of
the crystal itself.
The equation he developed,
Bragg's law, made it possible
to work out how the spots in
the diffraction pattern are
related to the specific
arrangement of
atoms in the crystal.
Two years on, and the Braggs
were awarded the Nobel Prize.
Impressive stuff.
Not only that, the Braggs
mentored a dream team of
crystallographers who went on to
work out the structures of
a huge range of molecules.
From Kathleen Lonsdale, JD
Bernal, Dorothy Hodgkin, to
David Phillips, John Kendrew,
and Max Perutz.
Remember him?
Plus Rosalind Franklin and
others even helped map the
structure of DNA, probably the
most famous result of x-ray
crystallography.
Today, the work hasn't
stopped.
Crystallography remains the
foremost technique for working
out the atomic structures of
almost anything, which is very
useful for finding out why
things behave the way they do.
From the metallic structure of
the blades of a jet turbine to
the immune system fighting
off viruses.
Turns out Max was right.
Modern crystallographers are
doing exactly the same thing
as the Braggs, just at a
larger scale with more
sophisticated mathematical
methods and
more impressive machines.
Crystallography is even reaching
beyond our planet.
The Curiosity Rover is now
performing x-ray diffraction
analysis of the soil on Mars.
But there's plenty
of unfinished
business back on Earth.
There are still many thousands
of complex molecules to look
at, and a lot more questions
to answer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]